tenemos aquí una rueda con una flecha
que puede girar una cosa que podrías
encontrarte en un juego de niños y una
vez que giras la flecha tenemos siete
posibles resultados aquí probables
cierto este es uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis o siete en cuatro de
estos resultados tenemos un elefante en
dos de ellos un ratón que parece que
está corriendo y tenemos un solo chango
haciendo acrobacias ahora preguntémonos
qué pasa si giramos esta flecha por
ejemplo 210 veces que vamos a girar la
flecha 210 veces
y yo quiero que tú pre digas cuál es el
número de veces que obtenemos el
elefante predice cuál es el número de
veces
y obtenemos obtenemos un elefante así es
que poner pausa el vídeo e inténtalo
estoy suponiendo que ya lo intentaste
una forma de pensar en esto es empezar
pensando en qué pasa con un giro de esta
flecha y empezamos con un giro y nos
queremos preguntar cuál es la
probabilidad de que en un giro de esta
flecha obtengamos un elefante ya hemos
visto cómo calcular esto porque la
flecha la vamos a girar de forma justa
entonces tenemos siete resultados aquí
probables así es que ponemos por aquí un
7 y luego vemos en cuántos de estos
siete resultados tenemos un elefante
tenemos aquí 12
y 4 así es que la probabilidad de
obtener un elefante girando una vez esta
flecha son 4 séptimos y bueno empezando
a pensar acerca de girar la flecha 210
veces pues sería razonable muy razonable
sobre todo si estamos girando muchísimas
veces la flecha uno podría esperar que 4
séptimas partes del tiempo obtuviéramos
un elefante acabamos de calcular aquí la
probabilidad teórica de obtener un
elefante a la hora de girar esta flecha
y eso nos informa que si fuera yo a
realizar un montón de experimentos
girando esta flecha de forma justa
debería de esperar que más o menos 4
séptimos partes del tiempo 4 séptimos
partes de los giros que haga caigan en
elefante entonces para hacer una
predicción razonable está muy bien decir
vamos a hacer 210 experimentos
los cuales yo esperaría que 4 séptimos
partes sean elefantes así es que vamos a
calcular esto 210 por cuatro séptimos
210 entre 7 son 30 y 30 por 4 son 120
así es que vamos a predecir qué vamos a
obtener 120 veces a un elefante 120
veces entonces mi predicción y tal vez
la tuya también es que si giramos la
flecha 210 veces yo predigo que 120 de
esas veces van a ser un elefante ahora
es muy importante pensar en qué es lo
que esto nos está diciendo y qué es lo
que no nos está diciendo aunque hay por
ejemplo podría obtener 121 elefantes
119 elefantes claro que sí por supuesto
que sí es muy razonable que obtengamos
un número distinto a este de hecho
también existe la posibilidad de que no
obtengamos ni un solo elefante aunque de
que todas las veces que giramos esta
flecha caiga en uno de los ratones o en
el chango tiene una probabilidad baja de
ocurrir pero claro qué podría suceder y
de la misma forma también podría pasar
que todas las 210 veces que giramos la
flecha obtengamos un elefante pero otra
vez eso tiene una probabilidad bastante
baja pero el chiste es que nos demos
cuenta que aquí no estamos asegurando
que vamos a obtener 120 veces al
elefante ok sería completamente
razonable que lo tuviéramos 125 veces
o incluso 200 veces o también podríamos
obtenerlo únicamente 90 veces y eso
sería bastante razonable esta es
simplemente una predicción si me obligas
a escoger un número para predecir
cuántos elefantes vamos a obtener yo
escogería este porque es el más probable
y por cierto tenemos que predecir el
número antes de empezar a girar la
flecha ok si giramos la flecha 210 veces
entonces el número de veces que podemos
obtener un elefante puede ir desde 0
hasta 210 pero de todos esos números la
predicción más razonable es 120 ok
porque esperamos obtener elefantes
aproximadamente 4 séptimas partes del
tiempo o sea 120 veces pero por supuesto
no hay nada que nos diga que no podemos
obtener 118 elefantes y no hay nada que
nos diga que 129 es una mala predicción
es simplemente que
si giramos la flecha 210 veces y la
probabilidad de obtener un elefante en
cada uno de esos 210 giros es 4 séptimos
entonces lo más razonable es pensar que
cuatro séptimos partes de las veces que
giremos la flecha vamos a obtener un
elefante o sea 120 veces en que hay 4
sept y más partes de 210